bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat hier la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat a auditionné marc
mortureux
le directeur général de l'ansés l'agencé
nationale de sécurité sanitaire
cette audition reporter sur l'avis rendu
par son agence concernant l'étude du
professeur séralini le 19 septembre
dernier ce professeur publié un rapport
sur les effets à long terme des ogm
associé à des pesticides un rapport
critique est contestée notamment par l'
agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
qui pointe notamment la faiblesse de ses
conclusions mais demandent néanmoins que
de nouvelles recherches réalisées sur
les effets à long terme des ogm
on écoute tout de suite donc cette
audition de marc mortureux le directeur
général de l'agencé nationale de
sécurité sanitaire
en tous les cas ce matin nous sommes
très heureux de votre présence monsieur
le président mortureux et nous expliquer
un peu mais bien sur les commentaires
que l'agencé a eu à faire sur l'étude de
très médiatisée c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire ce que je pense qu'il y
avait effectivement un plan de com ya
les politiques devraient s'en inspirer
peut-être par les temps qui courent je
suis pas sûr que si ce que la communauté
scientifique ci soit retrouvée c'est un
autre problème est en tous les cas je
souhaiterais aussi que vous nous fassiez
à pau l'historique de votre agence
monsieur le président parce que ça c'est
quand même né d'une fusion etc
peut-être que nos collègues ne maîtrise
pas tout à fait l'histoire de votre
agence et de re situer à la fois la
genèse mais aussi de mission
ok vous sans données et ensuite
évidemment nos collections évidemment là
pour écouter les commentaires que vous
avez à faire sur la communication faite
sur l'étude du professeur séralini là
dessus d'ailleurs j'aurai quelques
questions à vous poser sur bien sûr le
truc la question classique c'est
évidemment le problème des fois des
études statistiques à partir de quel
moment
c'est crédible et sais pas mais je crois
que vous êtes déjà exprimée est ce qui
m'a quand même troubles et je parle
devant jean bizet aussi puisqu'on a
cohabité à un office parlementaire
c'était il y avait déjà une étude sur
les perturbateurs endocriniens fait par
notre collègue barbier du temps je
pouvais aller un peu me nourrir l'esprit
d'étude scientifique à l'office et plus
le temps ça me prive suis frustré je
compense la nuit ici non mais c'est pas
forcément scientifique et donc monsieur
le noir bonjour pas encore mais
non il y avait quand même déjà à
l'époque je me rappelle d'avoir posé le
problème à l'office le problème de
savoir sur la durée des essais c'est un
problème qui était déjà évoquée et
ensuite
ces essais qui sont menées par ce qu'ils
demandent l'habilitation fin à
l'accréditation est donc le problème de
l'indépendance donc la longueur des
tests et le problème de la recherche
indépendante
j'ai toujours gelé souvent posée
d'ailleurs au directeur de l'inra et sur
lequel il avait des problèmes sur le dif
concernant le recrutement de doctorants
qu'on sait bien que les doctorants sur
les tests rendre les sciences dans les
laboratoires et que le il subissait une
pression pour ne pas s'occuper de ce
doigt domaine
l'inra en particulier des plantes
génétiquement modifiées je vous dis
aussi monsieur le président que je
n'aime pas le terme aux jem qui d'une
façon générale couvre tout un ensemble y
compris de vaccins de bière de le je
préfère m'occuper des pgm des plantes
génétiquement modifiées
parce que le débat à la fois
scientifique et sans doute socio
économique se porte sur qui porte sur
les plantes génétiquement modifiées
vraiment je suis sur ma lancée de cette
nuit et donc c'était des questions
allez simplement dire que toute façon
mis sur neo je confirme c'est à dire
brown monsieur daniel raoul mais surtout
je voudrais dire que je suis élu d'un
département qui a envisagé de faire un
référendum sur ce sujet et il a fallu
que l'europe l'arrêtent
sinon je crois que le refaire un homme
aurait eu lieu donc non plus
sérieusement les questions que l'on se
pose mais sûr nous espérons qu'on
pourrait nous éclairer
je rajouterais à ce qu'a dit 1 et raul
c'est que j'ai aussi entendu que le coût
de ces essais étaient quand même assez
difficile à répéter puisque quand on
parle de plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois et c'est la question qui se pose
qui finance pour que ce soit évidemment
sérieusement non furieusement et
loyalement fait voilà donc je crois
comme sans plus attendre
nos collègues piétine déjà su président
la parole de monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs donc je suis très
heureux en fait je ne suis que directeur
général de l' agence il ya un lien
président du conseil d'administration
qui d'ailleurs n'est pas nous mais
depuis assez longtemps mais voilà je
suis je suis directeur général et donc
pour moi c'est un grand plaisir d'avoir
cette occasion de pouvoir présenter
effectivement les résultats du travail
qu'on a fait sur la base de l'étude
séralini mais plus généralement
effectivement peut-être d'en profiter
pour dire quelques mots donc au départ
sur l' agence donc lan cesse un sachant
que donc j'ai ici franck fourès un qui
est avec moi qui est directeur adjoint
de la direction de l'évaluation des
risques à l'agencé qui a suivi tout
particulièrement le suit le sujet de
l'étude séralini et puis je vais être
rejoints par le professeur gérard l'as
far qui est le directeur général adjoint
de l'agencé alors peut-être un mot tout
d'abord effectivement sur sur la ssc
donc l' agence nationale de sécurité
sanitaire en charge de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail et qui est
en charge de l'évaluation des risques
dans donc un vaste domaine qui résulte
de la fusion
il y a deux ans un de l'afssa qui est l
agence en charge de toute la chaîne
alimentaire
et de l'afsset en charge des sujets de
santé environnement et santé travail
alors pourquoi cette fusion c'est une
agence donc aujourd'hui qui est en
charge à la fois toute une série de
sujets de santé humaine mais également
de façon plus large de santé et
bien-être animal et santé végétale avec
voilà l'homme dans son environnement au
sens large du terme
et quel est l'intérêt un d'avoir
regroupé ses différents domaines eh bien
je dirais tout simplement comme vous
l'avez un petit peu illustré sur le
transparent
le fait que ça nous permet pour une
source de danger
donnez un qui peut être une substance
chimique qui peut être un agent
biologique qui peut être des
rayonnements des agents physiques et
bien de pouvoir prendre en compte
l'ensemble des sources auxquelles nous
pouvons être soumis je dirais dans notre
vie quotidienne que ça soit en tant que
consommateur par l'alimentation
que ça soit en tant que travailleur au
travers des expositions professionnelles
ou que ça soit en tant que citoyens de
façon générale au travers de l'air qu'on
respire de l'eau et c'est donc de
pouvoir prendre en compte l'ensemble des
sources d'exposition pour évaluer les
risques et on comprend assez bien disons
un peu l'intérêt d'un tel modèle
intégratif qui se rapproche davantage de
la réalité
1 de l'environnement dans lequel on se
retrouve et je dois dire que donc on a
été créée depuis deux ans et c'est un
modèle qui suscite beaucoup d'intérêt à
l'international 1 je pense par exemple
aux états-unis au canada en europe
on est très originaux parce que
traditionnellement il ya un peu disons
tout un cadre qui existent dans le
domaine alimentaire qui souvent très
réglementé et puis voilà on a la f10 et
aux états unis par exemple et puis côté
environnemental on a les pieds en
allemagne on a le bfr sur le côté plutôt
alimentaire et puis on a le béa et
d'autres organisent plutôt sur les
aspects environnementaux avec des
cultures qui sont potentiellement assez
différente et ce qui est assez
intéressant avec la création de deux là
ne cessent enfin c'est d'essayer voilà
d'intégrer un peu l'ensemble de ces
éléments et je dirais également le fait
que cette fusion qui au départ n'a pas
été très simple parce que les différents
acteurs étaient un peu inquiets de voir
comment allait par exemple se situer les
sujets de santé des travailleurs dans un
ensemble beaucoup plus large ou à l
inverse un des sujets sur la santé
animale à l'intérieur d'un ensemble très
vaste dont évidemment le premier enjeu
est quand même la santé humaine comment
chacun de ces éléments allaient se
retrouver un peu dans l'ensemble et je
dois dire qu'aujourd'hui je crois que le
fait d'avoir eu énormément de débats à
l'occasion de la création de l' agence
énormément de concertation et je peux
vous assuré moi j'arrivais ni d'un côté
ni de l'autre
et heureusement d'ailleurs les débats
ont été particulièrement vifs mais je
crois que ça nous a aidés d'abord avec
un peu bousculé je pense que c'est pas
mauvais dans des logiques d' agence de
sécurité sanitaire de se reposer toute
une série de questions j'aime à dire que
un des plus grands risques qu'on a c'est
le risque d'accoutumance
1 donc ça je crois que c'est important
et puis je crois qu'on a créé un modèle
qui est assez originale à la fois par
une gouvernance qui est extrêmement
ouverte sur l'ensemble des parties
prenantes avec d'un côté disons une
expertise scientifique est extrêmement
protégé de toute intervention externe
donc ça il ya des procès sont pas y
revenir extrêmement strictes sur tout ce
qui concerne en particulier la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts dans
le process scientifique mais en même
temps en amont comme en aval des lieux
d'échangé de dialogue par exemple on a
des comités d'orientation thématique
auprès de notre conseil d'administration
qui lui même est constitué un peu autour
des 5 collèges du grenelle de
l'environnement donc un peu tous les les
partenaires pour pouvoir débattre avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes de
notre programme de travail de nos
priorités d'être à l'écouté de ces
différents acteurs pour pouvoir intégrer
dans notre programme de travail
un certain nombre de préoccupations qui
peuvent être portés par les uns ou par
les autres donc ça c'est un élément
important et puis en aval des efforts
disons de restitution de discussion nous
avons dans nos missions aussi de
contribuer au débat public et par
exemple sur le sujet qui nous concerne
aujourd'hui on a sorti notre avis le
lundi le mardi matin on faisait une
réunion avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes était d'ailleurs très
appréciée parce que c'est l'occasion de
pouvoir échanger de pouvoir expliquer
davantage de pouvoir confronter un peu
les points de vue des uns et des autres
sans chercher nécessairement est ce que
l'ensemble des acteurs autour de la
table soit d'accord
1 et sortent avec tous disons la même
opinion c'est pas l'objet mais ça permet
de contribuer effectivement à la
compréhension mutuelle
d autres alors de façon concrète 1
lagence donc à cet objectif
un de faire des évaluations de risques
donc pour ça on a des collectifs
d'experts donc qui sont sélectionnés à
la fois pour les compétences mais aussi
au regard des exigences donc très
strictes en matière de prévention des
conflits d'intérêts cette activité d'
expertise collective et contradictoires
se fait soit dans un cadre réglementaire
qui est déterminé un comme par exemple
les produits phytosanitaires ou les
plantes génétiquement modifiées
également et dans ce cadre là on évalue
des dossiers qui sont fournies par les
industriels dans un cadre réglementaire
avec un certain nombre de lignes
directrices soit on travaille en réponse
à des saisines que l'on reçoit soit des
ministères soient des différentes
parties prenantes qui sont à notre
conseil d'administration et qui ont le
pouvoir de saisine soit disons dans le
cadre d'autosaisine et j'en profite
messieurs les présidents 1 pour noter
que le parlement aujourd'hui n'a pas
informé lmnp de pouvoir de saisine 1 sur
l' agence mais moi je tiens à rappeler
que les agences de sécurité sanitaire
ont été créés par la volonté du
parlement et que en ce qui nous concerne
on est totalement ouverts qu'il y est
d'ailleurs dé pouvoir de saisine
formelle ou pas à répondre à des
sollicitations que vous pourriez avoir
pour qu'on essaye de vous apporter les
éléments d'éclairage qui peuvent être
utiles par rapport à tel ou tel type de
sujet d'une façon générale on est sur
une logique de séparation entre
l'évaluation des risques et la gestion
des risques nous on est en charge de
l'évaluation des risques la gestion
derrière ce sont les ministères et donc
notre rôle en ambre ou simple passé
d'apporter de façon obsessive peut aussi
objective que possible aussi complète
que possible et qu on actualise
régulièrement tout l'état des données
scientifiques de ce que l'on 7 mais
également de mettre en évidence le cas
échéant ce que l'on ne sait pas les
incertitudes qui peuvent y avoir pour
aider les gestionnaires du risque plus
généralement un peu l'ensemble des
acteurs à va prendre des décisions qui
soient adaptées à la réalité 2
de l'état des connaissances
scientifiques alors nous avons donc
également et pour finir sur cette
présentation rapide de lagence donc des
laboratoires qui sont répartis sur les
territoires qui sont essentiellement
donc dans le domaine santé animale
sécurité sanitaire des aliments et santé
végétale
globalement notre rôle c'est d'apporter
aux pouvoirs publics toute
l'infrastructure technique nécessaire
pour qu'il puisse faire réaliser toutes
les plans de contrôle et de surveillance
qui sont prévus dans le cadre de la
réglementation anticiper un d'éventuels
émergence qui peuvent exister faire de
la surveillance épidémiologique et donc
ça fait partie également des missions de
lagence alors évidemment on est exposé
sur un champ qui est extrêmement vaste
aujourd'hui donc on va parler
aujourd'hui plutôt des plantes
génétiquement modifiées et des produits
phytosanitaires qui sont deux sujets
très importants 10 au niveau de l'
agence on s'occupe également des
biocides on s'occupe de l'impact des
téléphones portables sur la santé on va
s'occuper des sujets qui touchent aux
expositions professionnelles sujets
comme l'amiante les perturbateurs
endocriniens tout ce qui est les
substances chimiques et toutes les
questionnements qui peut y avoir autour
les nanomatériaux
voilà un très vaste champ de compétence
et voilà que vous dire on est
globalement bien d'occuper est fortement
sollicité alors notre effectif où il
pour finir quelques quelques chiffres
clés donc on a au total 1300 personnes à
peu près la moitié dans nos laboratoires
et la moitié dit long sur l'ensemble des
autres activités auxquelles s'ajoutent
environ 800 experts externes qui sont
rassemblées dans une bonne vingtaine de
collectifs d'experts dans nos différents
champs de compétences voilà alors j'en
viens si vous voulez bien plus
spécifiquement donc à ce qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui par rapport à la la
publication donc de l'étude du
professeur gilles eric séralini sachant
que donc le gouvernement le jour même de
la sortie de cette publication nous a
posé deux questions la première c'est
déterminer si cette publication est de
nature à remettre en cause ou non les
conclusions des évaluations précédentes
dans le cadre réglementaire sur cette
plante génétiquement modifiée donc le
maïs nk603xmon810 puisque il ya les deux
deux questions qui sont posées et la
deuxième question nous a été posée c'est
d'évaluer si à la lumière de cette étude
et de l'ensemble des connaissances
actuelles il y a lieu de remettre en
cause les lignes directrices actuelles
en vigueur dans le cadre de la
réglementation européenne
alors pour répondre à ces questions donc
on a constitué un groupe d' expertise
collective d'urgence parce que bon voilà
on avait un mois 1 pour faire le travail
alors composé d'experts un trait
pluridisciplinaire avec en particulier
les compétences sur le côté
biotechnologies mais également des
compétences sur le côté produits
phytosanitaires donc avec différents
types de compétences de toxicologues
nutritionniste génotoxicité des
différents domaines de compétence dont
on a besoin et vous avez d'ailleurs dans
la vie et puis également projeté la
composition de ce groupe d'experts
alors vous imaginez un travail depuis la
création de la ss disons à des règles
extrêmement strictes par rapport bison
ou risque de conflit d'intérêts sans
pourra y revenir on a des dispositions
extrêmement cadré on a veillé évidemment
donc avoir les compétences nécessaires
mais également évidemment à faire très
attention par rapport aux liens
d'intérêts un des différents partenaires
mais nous avons aussi essayé de faire en
sorte d'avoir un groupe d'experts je
dirais à se renouveler de pour avoir
aussi un regard un peu neuf disons sur
un peu l'ensemble de la question qui est
posée avec donc notamment comme
président du groupe donc un directeur de
recherche de l'inra qui est d'ailleurs
un peu spécialiste des questions faibles
doses des mélanges 1 qui sont parmi les
sujets effectivement qui sont posées au
travers de cette étude
alors bien évidemment toutes les
déclarations publiques d'intérêts sont
sur le site de l'agencé comme évidemment
les règles systématiquement qu'on
applique dans le cadre de nos procédures
alors beaucoup de choses ont été dites
depuis depuis un peu plus d'un mois
maintenant sur cette étude de séralini
clairement l' agence n'a pas souhaité
réagir à chaud hein
pour avoir le temps de faire son travail
même si un mois ça reste court mais
c'est vrai que voilà le temps de l'
expertise n'est pas tout à fait le temps
des médias mais on revendique un d'avoir
effectivement le temps de faire notre
travail est d'apporter une véritable
valeur ajoutée par une analyse aussi
complète que possible non seulement de
l'étude elle-même mais en la resituant
dans l'ensemble des études et des
données scientifiques disponibles avec
une approche à la fois très rigoureux
sur le plan scientifique mais aussi en
veillant voilà garder une attitude je
dirais de respect de deux distances pour
travailler dans la sérénité
et puis porter attention aux signaux qui
peuvent être tirées d'un tel travail au
delà de ses faiblesses sachant que on
est plus en plus confrontés en fait
comme ça il ya une étude qui sort était
présenté comme apportant la preuve de
ceci ou de cela est que en tant
qu'agence notre rôle n'est pas d'être un
super comité de lecture d'une
publication scientifique et que c'est un
petit peu la difficulté qu'on rencontre
de plus en plus nous notre rôle c'est
pas d'aller prendre des décisions en
général c'est difficile
un de prendre dessinant sur la base
d'une seule étude donc c'est vraiment
prendre le temps de re situer les
éléments nouveaux qui peuvent être
apportées par une étude dans l'ensemble
des connaissances et ce que nous avons
essayé de faire alors nous avons
souhaité aussi dans notre méthodologie
entendre les principaux protagonistes de
ces débats l'auteur de l'étude
bien sûr que nous avons auditionné donc
le 10 octobre dernier ce qui nous a
permis d'ailleurs de récupérer quelques
éléments d'information complémentaires
et aussi un certain nombre de données
brutes par rapport à la publication ce
qu'une des difficultés qu'on rencontre
c'est que il a prévu nous l'a d'ailleurs
dit plusieurs autres publications à
venir et que à ce stade mais a quand
même toute une série d'informations qui
ne sont pas disponibles au travers
disons de la publication qui était sorti
donc il y à un mois
nous avons aussi souhaité donc
auditionné générations futures au
travers de son président françois
veillerette
plus spécifiquement sur la partie un fit
aux sanitaires
et puis nous avons aussi un sollicité la
firme monsanto qui d'ailleurs n'a pas
souhaité en faire une audition orale
mais qui nous a adressé une contribution
écrite
sachant que voilà l'ensemble des comptes
rendus et ce document donc sont à
disposition sur le site de l' agence
alors nous avons enfin veiller à nous
coordonner avec les autres instances qui
ont travaillé et qui travaillent sur
cette étude vont en france le haut
conseil des biotechnologies avec
d'ailleurs il ya un expert commun entre
le conseil scientifique 1 du hcb et
notre notre groupe d'experts que nous
avons mis en place avec des points
d'échangé d'informations même si par la
spécificité de nos missions respectives
et en particulier on s'occupe des
aspects aussi phytosanitaires qui ne
relèvent pas du champ du hcb
nous avons l'un et l'autre mené de façon
indépendante
nos propres expertises en europe nous
avons été évidemment en lien avec l'efsa
qui a d'ailleurs décidé de travailler en
deux temps un ils ont sorti très vite
une première analyse critique de l'étude
et ils prévoient donc mi-novembre de
sortir disons un avis qui va intégrer
les contributions d'ailleurs des
différentes agences et bien évidemment
nous avons transmises à l'efsa le
résultat de notre travail
et puis aussi avec de nombreux
homologues comme vous l'avez vu beaucoup
d' agences les allemands les néerlandais
notamment donc ont sorti très vite
disons d avis alors nous nous rejoignons
un très largement sur plusieurs points
essentiels de faiblesse de l'étude sur
lequel on va revenir et surtout des
conclusions qui en sont tirées par son
auteur mais voilà nous avons cherché à
aller au delà de cette analyse critique
en faisant le point d autres études
disponibles et en analysant les
conclusions qu'ils pouvaient en être
tirées alors vous savez il ya eu un
certain nombre de méta analyse c'est à
dire de travaux qui ont été faits ces
dernières années pour voile a balayé
toutes les études qui existent un peu
sur ces sujets d'effets à long terme des
plantes génétiquement modifiées
éventuellement associée donc à des
produits phytosanitaires en regardant de
près ces méta analyse nous avons
identifié en fait que deux études qui
sont assez comparables à l'étude qui a
été fait par gilles eric séralini donc
lui avait présentée que c'était la
première étude qui était fait c'est pas
tout à fait vrai mais d'un autre côté
c'est vrai qu'il y a assez peu d'études
disponibles et donc vous le verrez voilà
vous avez un tableau là pour comparer un
peu les les différentes études alors sur
l'étude séralini donc c'est la première
colonne bon elle a clairement pour
objectif d'étudier la toxicité à long
terme donc de l'herbicide roundup et
d'un maïs tolérant donc au glyphosate
qui est la substance active du round up
est donc cette toxicité via
l'alimentation
on est bien sûr une question de sécurité
sanitaire des aliments alors le
protocole d'étude il prévoit un nombre
relativement important d'animaux au
total 200 rats mais qui sont répartis
dans de très nombreux groupes il ya
vingt 20 groupes de dire à qui pourquoi
c'est parce que l'auteur a cherché à
faire beaucoup de choses disons à la
fois dans le cadre de son étude est donc
ces groupes de dire ah eh bien il ya ce
qu'on appelle les groupes témoins c'est
à dire ceux qui n'ont pas consommé 1 de
maïs génétiquement modifié donc qu'ils
sont un petit peu la référence donc des
groupes de dira donc des deux sexes et
ensuite toute une série de groupes qui
donc ont consommé du maïs génétiquement
modifié dans différentes proportions
avec des doses ou sandoz disons et des
doses plus ou moins forte de roundup
dont une dose 1 la plus faible qui
correspond à des niveaux qui peuvent
correspondre à ce à quoi effectivement
peut être exposé qui sont au niveau des
limites maximales de résidus qui sont
prévus donc aux comptes au travers en
particulier de l'eau 1 et puis deux
autres doses qu'ils sont al'inverse très
élevé et notamment la troisième qui est
très très très élevé alors les auteurs
de l'étude décrivent une mortalité et
l'incidence des tumeurs plus précoce et
plus importante dans les groupes traités
ou qui ont consommé donc les plantes
génétiquement modifiées par rapport au
groupe témoin donc les auteurs donc en
déduisent des effets à long terme sur la
santé de la consommation
un de ces plantes génétiquement
modifiées associés ou non à des résidus
de pesticides avec très clairement un
l'objectif un des auteurs est temps de
mettre en évidence les insuffisances du
cadre réglementaire actuel et pour être
clair
avec deux points principaux 1 qu'ils ont
sur lequel disons il conteste le cadre
réglementaire actuel sur la partie pgm
un génétiquement modifiés l'auteur
considère que les études qui sont
imposés pour vérifier l'absence de
risques chroniques un donc sur le long
terme sont insuffisantes en particulier
donc sur la durée des tests requis donc
ça c'est le premier point
et puis sur la partie phytosanitaires ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que la
réglementation prévoit disons deux
niveaux il ya donc les substances
actives qui composent donc les produits
phytosanitaires et puis ensuite il ya
les produits commerciaux au niveau des
substances actives le cadre
réglementaire prévoit de très nombreuses
études dont des études à deux ans un des
études long terme au niveau de la
substance active donc en l'occurrence le
glyphosate n'est ensuite au niveau de
l'autorisation des produits commerciaux
un produit commercial est composé d'une
ou plusieurs substances actives avec des
cons formulant et la réglementation
prévoit qu'il ya toute une série de
tests sur chacun des composants 1,2 du
produit
évidemment en se basant sur toutes les
données qui concerne la substance active
mais ensuite en ce qui concerne le
mélange
la réglementation prévoit un test de
toxicité aiguë c'est à dire court terme
l'objectif est de voir si au travers de
ce test on constate des différences
importantes ou pas par rapport aux
propriétés connu de la substance active
s'il ya peu de différences ont senti à
la en s'appuyant sur toutes les données
qui existe un des différents éléments
si on constate des différences à ce
moment-là réglementairement peut
demander des études complémentaires
voilà il conteste un le fait qu'il n'y
ait pas d'étude long terme systématique
sur l'ensemble des mélanges donc c'est
pour simplement bien bien cadrer les
questionnements qui sont posées alors
nous verrons que l' expertise 1 comme
celles de nombreux autres agences
conduit à considérer un au travers de
l'étude séralini qu'il n'est pas
possible sur une base scientifique
d'établir au travers des résultats de
l'étude de lien de cause à effet
entre la consommation de la plante
génétiquement modifiée
associer le cas échéant avec donc des
résidus de pesticides et l'apparition
des tumeurs alors peut-être en mots
assez simple un donc voyez c'est des
groupes qui sont en taille limitée de
dire à l'espèce qui a été choisi ça a
été beaucoup dit c'est une espèce de
rats qui spontanément dans des
proportions assez importantes au cours
de la vie développe des tumeurs donc par
rapport à l'étude qui est mené c'est
vrai qu'il ya automatiquement un certain
nombre de ce que je dirais entre
guillemets de faux positif c'est-à-dire
de tumeurs qui apparaissent sur des rats
qui ont consommé de la plante
génétiquement modifiée et pour lequel
cette tumeur serait très probablement
apparue sans nécessairement qui est
cette consommation
donc c'est pas rédhibitoire et notre
position est pas de dire en soi
le choix de cette espèce de rat est
nécessairement mauvais mais à partir du
moment où il ya dix ans cette
caractéristique il faut des groupes de
taille très importante pour que
l'analyse des écarts entre les groupes
témoins et les groupes un qui ont
consommé la plante génétiquement
modifiée pour que l'analyse de ces
écarts puisse est statistiquement
représentatif et que globalement un les
spécialistes considèrent que ces 50 80
rappard groupe minimum qu'il faudrait
avoir pour faire ça donc voilà des
faiblesses sur le plan hamp a tué
statistiques et méthodologiques qui
apparaissent et qui conduisent voilà a
considéré que cette étude n'est pas en
mesure ne permet pas de remettre en
cause les analyses qui ont été faites
précédemment
on pourra bien sûr revenir disons là
dessus juste un mot sur le fait que donc
à côté il ya une étude sakamoto donc la
deuxième qui vise à évaluer la sécurité
à long terme d'un soja génétiquement
modifiés qui est fortement consommée au
japon
alors là c'est une étude dont les
caractéristiques sont plus proches inde
et des protocoles disons classique dit
ocde qui sont utilisés et voilà le
résultat de cette étude d entre
parenthèses qui était cité dans un
certain nombre d'endroits mais qui n'a
pas dû être beaucoup lu dans le détail
parce que quand on l'a identifiée elle
n'existait qu'en japonais
donc on l'a fait traduire donc c'était
intéressant aussi de voir ça va
clairement au travers de cette étude
qu'un certain nombre aussi de faiblesse
ils n'ont pas constaté de différence est
liée au soja génétiquement modifiés et
puis il ya une troisième étude l'étude
malatesta qui a pour but d'étudier les
effets hépatique d'une alimentation
contenant 14 % de soja génétiquement
modifiés et selon les auteurs là aussi
l'alimentation n'a pas entraîné de
différences significatives concernant la
mortalité
le poids des animaux de leur foi puisque
c'était là un sujet plus sur les effets
hépatique
bon voilà donc les études telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui
alors pour conclure un peu sur ces
différents éléments laissent donc tir de
ce travail plusieurs conclusions
la première ainsi qu'au delà d'ailleurs
des critiques méthodologiques
le cese considère donc par rapport à
l'étude un séralini que la faiblesse
centrale c'est que les conclusions
avancées par les auteurs sont
insuffisamment soutenu par les données
présentées dans cette publication c'est
à dire assez clairement il ya une
surinterprétation un de ceux que l'on
peut tirer des résultats
disons de l'étude et c'est ainsi voilà
qu'on répond très clairement la première
question 1 sur le fait que les résultats
de ce travail de recherche ne permettent
pas de remettre en cause les évaluations
réglementaire précédente tant sur le
maïs nk603xmon810 bien sûr revenir un
plus en détail met le deuxième point que
nous avons souhaité mettre en avant
c'est comme j'ai dit c'est qu'il ya peu
un d'études sur les effets potentiels à
long terme des plantes génétiquement
modifiées associés donc aux préparations
phytopharmaceutiques alors clairement
c'est une préoccupation 1 qui rejoint un
des travaux et des préoccupations qui
sont portées par l' agence puisque nous
avions donc dans le cadre de la
réglementation sur les plantes
génétiquement modifiées rendu un travail
il ya deux ans début 2011 qui visait
justement à recommander que le cadre
réglementaire européen soit renforcé
pour intégrer ce qu'on appelle des tests
90 jours donc c'est des études peu
intermédiaire type sub chronique de les
rendre systématiquement obligatoire ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
cette évolution de la réglementation
européenne est en cours depuis deux ans
elle devrait bientôt aboutir et nous nos
premières recommandations
c'est que déjà ce nouveau cadre
réglementaire qui intègre l'ensemble de
nos recommandations sur ce point là
puissent être adoptées disons le plus
rapidement possible c'est le premier
point après au delà un du renforcement
cours du cadre réglementaire
on émet plusieurs recommandations la
première pas c'est de considérer comme
il ya peu d'études 1 aujourd'hui sur les
effets à long terme c'est que oui on
considère que ça vaut la peine d'engager
de nouvelles études sur la question des
effets à long terme des plantes
génétiquement modifiées associés aux
pesticides mais avec l'idée qu' il faut
d'abord bien se mettre d'accord sur les
objectifs qu'on vise sur le type
d'ailleurs de plantes génétiquement
modifiées ce que c'est celle là le nk603
ou est ce que il n'y a pas intérêt
d'ailleurs peut-être il ya d'autres
plantes qui sont davantage utilisés qui
pourrait peut-être est recommandé de
bien définir les objectifs visés donc le
protocole et puis de le faire dans un
cadre le plus indépendant possible
donc si possible sur financement public
et que la nes est prête en association
avec d'autres partenaires et notamment
d'autres agences sanitaires au niveau
national au niveau européen à travailler
à l'établissement des principes généraux
de tels protocoles d'étude la deuxième
recommandation c'est de renforcer les
recherches sur les effets des
expositions cumulées un ce qu'on appelle
les effets cocktails l'agencé investis
sur le sujet il ya un projet qui a été
soutenu par line r1 dit périclès
mais clairement on est vraiment dans une
problématique aujourd'hui de recherche
c'est complexe trouver des méthodologies
pour pouvoir bien caractérisés disons
les différentes situations que l'on peut
retrouver parce qu'évidemment le sujet
des mélanges part
d'une complexité terrifiante en terre me
disant de nombre de possibilités
possible donc il ya besoin de développer
des méthodes douces ou alternatives a
systématiquement des expérimentations
animales et on est vraiment dans une
logique de recherche et qui dépasse
d'ailleurs la simple logique substances
actives co formulant des pesticides
c'est donc dans un cadre plus général
mais qu'on peut trouver aussi là dessus
et puis notre troisième recommandation
mais qui constitue un peu la conséquence
logique des deux points précédents et
qui s'inscrit donc dans un cadre plus
large que ce dossier spécifique c'est
nous considérons que en tant qu agence
de sécurité sanitaire dans un certain
nombre de cas nous aurions besoin de
pouvoir mobiliser des financements
publics soit au niveau national soit au
niveau européen dédié à la réalisation
d'études et de recherches d'envergure
puisque on pourra y revenir
effectivement sur les coûts on est là
sur des études qui sont potentiellement
très coûteuse et visant à consolider les
connaissances sur les risques sanitaires
insuffisamment documenté alors
clairement à la question du financement
public
un d'études et recherches base s'inscrit
dans un paysage scientifique constitué
de publications d'origines diverses
on a d'un côté des études réglementaires
qui sont financées par les industriels
et de l'autre on a des travaux de
recherche publics aux moyens plus
limités et dont les orientations
prioritaires de recherche ne vise pas
nécessairement à investiguer des effets
sanitaires potentiels peu documentée à
ce jour et que typiquement la
réalisation de ce type d'étude lourdes
type toxicologiques
c'est objectivement pas forcément les
thématiques les plus excitantes sur un
plan strictement scientifique et qui ne
correspond pas forcément effectivement
aux priorités des organismes de
recherche
alors cette situation n'est pas
spécifique aux plantes génétiquement
modifiées
1 d'autres domaines un peuvent être
également marquée par un manque de
connaissances scientifiques et une
attentes sociétales particulièrement
aigu en matière de recherche publique
indépendante
alors je vais être clair il finirait
là-dessus notre but n'est pas en soi de
réclamer un et serments plus d'argent
public on est dans un contexte de toute
façon qui est complexe c'est simplement
le fait que les mécanismes tels qu'ils
existent aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'argent sur la recherche
publique
c'est le fait que nous en tant qu agence
de sécurité sanitaire
et je dirais pour crédibiliser un peu
l'ensemble du dispositif où on est dans
le cadre réglementaire amené à s'appuyer
très largement sur les études fournies
par les industriels est en soi c'est un
bon principe que ça soit aux industriels
qui veulent mettre sur le marché un
produit qu'ils aient apporté la preuve
de l'innocuité de leurs produits
mais c'est le fait que une fois de temps
en temps quand encore une fois nous on
prend les études industrielles on
regarde aussi tout ce qui existe dans la
littérature scientifique et bien dans
quelques cas voilà on a des
questionnements et il ya assez peu
d'études disponibles et de diversité de
sources d'informations et que c'est
vraiment que dans des cas bien
spécifiques et pour crédibiliser un peu
l'ensemble du dispositif on puisse
mobiliser encore une fois c'est pas
d'avoir d'argent à nous mais qu'on
puisse mobiliser des financements pour
pouvoir réaliser en toute indépendance
un certain nombre d'études
complémentaires et qui peuvent être
coûteuse et donc c'est effectivement là
une question n'a pas aujourd'hui les
moyens par rapport à ça et simplement de
nous appuyer pour faire un peu ce
constat sur ce qui existe aux états unis
où il ya le ce qu'on appelle national
toxicology program en tipi qui est un
programme justement interagences au
niveau fédéral qui est dotée là en
l'occurrence sauf un montant assez
important il ya un peu plus de 120
millions de dollars et qui justement est
destinée à pouvoir dans un cadre de
discussions entre les différentes
grandes agences publiques décidé que sur
tel ou tel sujet ça a été le cas par
exemple à deux ans ils ont lancé une
grosse étude autour des sujets des
perturbateurs endocriniens sur le
bisphénol à des études extrêmement cadré
en toute indépendance pour travailler
voilà sur le sujet voilà alors je
voudrais juste en conclusion dire que
cette proposition d'ailleurs rejoint une
des recommandations faites dans le
rapport de la mission sénatoriale sur
les pesticides
sa présidente est ici sophie primas qui
a fait une analyse très approfondie de
la question de l'évaluation des produits
phytosanitaires et qui disons contient
plusieurs propositions qui rejoigne
effectivement pleinement nos propres
constats et puis je finirai par le fait
que cette proposition de voir comment
dix ont créé des mécanismes pour
mobiliser des moyens
lorsqu'on en a besoin c'est quelque
chose que d'ailleurs avant même l étude
séralini nous avions clairement
explicitées dans la contribution que
nous avons faite aux assises de la
recherche et de l'enseignement supérieur
qui est un des aspects qu'on a qu'on a
évoqué voilà monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
quelques éléments voilà de présentation
que je voulais vous faire
j'ai déjà quatre demandes de prise de
parole et attendait du calm and north
donnant l droite ne peut pas parler
monsieur jean bizet d'abord merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général je vous remercie de
nous avoir dressé un petit peu le
tableau de cette étude est d'avoir
rappelé également l'existence des
agences et je ne me permets de rappeler
que c'est nos deux anciens collègues
charles des cours et et notre collègue
huriez qui avait précisément dans cette
maison lamy mimi années 95 96 mis en
place ces agences coiffer entre
guillemets par une autorité européenne
une autorité européenne et on a vu que
toute cette architecture a été
particulièrement efficace
il y a très peu d'années lorsqu'il a
fallu diagnostiquer l'origine du de
l'escherichia coli qui provenait d'une
graine de soja bio en germination
donc on a quand même en europe une
architecture excessivement performantes
au travers de ses agences et de cette
autorité européenne pour essayer de
rassurer nos concitoyens
j'ajoute et vous en avez parlé de la
création du hcb qui a fait suite je
dirais à la loi de 2008 notre présent
raul sait très bien à quoi je vais faire
illusion je suis déçu je suis très déçu
que ce haut conseil
ce haut conseil notamment au travers de
son comité économique social et éthique
ne fonctionne pas bien
1 il ya deux comités un comité
scientifique à comité économique social
et éthique
pourquoi il ne fonctionne pas bien non
seulement parce qu'au niveau de ce
comité est bien la proportion des pros
ou des antilles et deux tiers un tiers
dans le sens des antilles aurait fallu
que ce soit à peu près équilibré mais là
on est dans le règlement père j'en avais
parlé au ministre de l'époque monsieur
borloo
même pas pu rectifier la chose mais
surtout l' architecture du hcb avait été
conçu de façon à ce que le comité
scientifique donne des avis et
uniquement des avis et le comité
économique scientifique et éthique fasse
des recommandations
or si ça fonctionne mal c'est
précisément parce que personne ne reste
à ta place au niveau du comité
économique social et éthique
c'est à dire que les membres de ce
comité veulent s'arroger le droit de
parler de de la chose scientifique alors
que c'est naulleau c'est le rôle
uniquement des experts des scientifiques
voilà pourquoi ça fonctionne mal je l'
ai dit à l'époque que j'ai démissionné
au bout d'un an je serai un peu plus
court donc voila moi je voulais le
rappeler donc si je parle des agents si
je parle de lui du haut conseil
c'est pour souligner si vous voulez
c'est qu'on a tout fait pour créer de la
confiance
or plus on a créé plus on a généré de
l'incompréhension de l'inquiétude de nos
concitoyens et ça c'est dû à deux choses
tout simplement des communication
intempestive des uns ou des autres
notamment des politiques nous ne sommes
pas exemple de critiquer le sujet et
puis je ne rentrerai pas sauf si vous me
questionner monsieur le président sur
les contre vérités qui ont été émises
par monsieur séralini qui avant d'être
un chercheur et un militant c'est son
droit
sauf qu'en l'occurrence il s'est
positionné comme un manipulateur choses
sont très claires je peux je peux en
répondre là dessus il ya deux choses qui
me trouble dans cette étude la première
c'est qu'au bout du quatrième mois
il a annoncé avoir découvert un certain
nombre de choses
or un chercheur qui par définition
athlétique aurait dû de façon collégiale
alerter la communauté scientifique
internationale en disant je suis en face
d'un problème de santé publique au bout
de simplement du 4e mois il a attendu
deux ans pour le faire donc il y a
manipulation voilà j'en arrête là - mais
conclusion c'est que en la matière
en termes de propriété des traits
génétiques propriété intellectuelle des
traits génétiques
nous avons perdu la france a perdu la
france a perdu également l' expertise
parce que les chercheurs sont partis
donc moi la question est la suivante
monsieur le directeur général est-ce que
nous pouvons éviter de faire des études
des expérimentations sur des animaux de
laboratoire
parce que derrière tout cela il ya quand
même des souffrances animales est passé
à des méthodes beaucoup plus moderne
tél la toxi génomique et c'est qu'ils
nous apporteront beaucoup plus
d'informations beaucoup moins cher et
beaucoup plus rapide
merci madame prima peut-être présidente
non mais je vous sollicite en tant que
président merci monsieur le président
merci de me donner la parole je vous
remercie monsieur le directeur général
pour cette intervention de ce matin
pourra faire référence effectivement au
travail de la mission d'information ton
nombreux collègues sont ici et la
rapporteuse n'est pas là mais elle se
joint évidemment à nicole bonnefoy à
cette étude vous dire que évidemment les
recommandations que vous formulez ce
matin vont dans le sens des
recommandations également de la mission
d'information dire que nous appelons de
nos voeux ce fonds abondé de façon
publique ou privée mais qui vous
permettrait de faire des études de façon
indépendante des études de long terme
des études qui nous manque aujourd'hui
on voit bien dans l'exposé vous faites
aujourd'hui trois études sur ces sujets
aussi importants
ce n'est pas suffisant et c'est de la
responsabilité publique de prendre en
charge un sujet aussi important
mais dans la sérénité qui doit être la
vôtre avec le recul et l expertise
simplement je vais peut-être aller dans
votre sens dire aussi que vous avez
besoin de de moyens ces moyens sont
souvent importés par les fonds
nécessaires à aux autorisations de mise
sur le marché qui sont qui sont réglés
par les industriels et qui vous
permettraient aujourd'hui d'avoir plus
des effets d'effectifs si nos amis de
bercy vous permettait de crever le
plafond d'emplois qui aujourd'hui vous
empêche de
merci monsieur le président il ya les
fonds aujourd'hui pour faire des études
oui nos amis entre guillemets offs et
les nôtres ont fatigué par ce sont les
nôtres voilà dos pièce probable de
plafond d'emploi je sais qu'il est un
problème récurrent et important pour
l'esn cesse et qui permettrait de donner
des moyens en expertise et en sommes
nécessaires et c'est un sujet sur lequel
je pense il faudra que les législateurs
se penchent d'une façon ou d'une autre
voilà donc nos recommandations vont
exactement dans le même sens que ce
matin ce sont des sujets que ce soit les
pesticides ou les plantes génétiquement
modifiées qui me qui demande la sérénité
qui demande de l'expertisé qui me
demande surtout d'écouter tout le monde
parce que tout le monde a besoin d'être
écoutés mais qui demande beaucoup de
recul donc je propose que votre agent
soit vraiment au coeur des ailes et
moyens de mener ces travaux tant sur le
plan financier que sur le plan humain
merci madame renée nicoux oui moi aussi
je voudrais remercier le dirait monsieur
directeur pour cette présentation et
souligné l'importance qu'il y à avoir
une agence nationale qui est
indépendante pour pouvoir tirer les
conclusions nécessaires sur ce type de
produits et je voudrais revenir aux
sujets qu'ils qui nous concerne vraiment
aujourd'hui concernant ces études
réalisées par professeur séralini et
peut-être cela m'a échappé mais dans la
présentation que vous avez fait je n'ai
pas entendu parler de l'espèce de rats
utilisé par monsanto dans ses études et
donc je voudrais que l'on puisse faire
des comparaisons avec ce ce qui a été
utilisé dans un premier temps et d'autre
part je trouve que votre conclusion la
première conclusion semble un peu sévère
par rapport à aux résultats de l'étude
séralini dans la mesure où il est dit
que ben elle n'apporte pas d'éléments
supplémentaires en revanche vous avez
dit auparavant qu'elle permette qu'elle
était un peu une alerte par rapport à la
toxicité possible mais qu'ils avaient
besoin de davantage de recherches et que
sur la durée il y avait besoin de faire
d'autres recherches donc
je pense qu'il y a la prolongation
nécessaire de ses études pour rassurer
les usagers que nous sommes tous deux
produits qui ont un moment était soumis
à ces à ces traitements que ce soit les
ogm consommée par les animaux ou les ogm
que nous sommes susceptibles de
consommer directement après
transformation ne serait-ce que les
céréales qui sont donnés aux enfants non
justement
le contest c'est interdit avec tout
toute production de doji m est donc de
deux tourteaux et cetera mais je
voudrais dire président que c'est une
très bonne idée d'avoir fait cette
rencontre ce matin lorsque je crois
qu'elle est important que je crois que
c'est l'objet même de poids lefebvre
régulièrement parce que je crois que ça
pourrait être important pour nous et
vous le comprendrez que je suis très
attentif président du groupe d'études de
l'élevage avec ce problème des ogm nous
sommes très très interrogatif vous
pensez bien donc très attentifs surtout
que lorsqu'il paraît des publications
des fois on dit le mal est fait les
journaux on a vu qu'elle est corps quel
on pleure ils ont donné
même s'il ya eu des modifications à brel
était beaucoup moins un grand titre
et puis il fallait presque rechercher la
grandeur donc en disant que cette étude
c'était très interrogatif mais le mal
est et est souvent faible et je me
rappelle quand même que l'agriculture
mais la filière d'élevage avait tant
subi de pertes après ce qu'on appelait
la vache folle les farines animales et
toutes les conséquences qu'a pu avoir
pour le monde agricole et ce pendant des
années ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
être très vigilant mais être très très
attentif parce que ça a été
catastrophique
donc je crois que c'est très important
que il y est absolument plus d'études
très sérieuse
c'est ce que
je demande à van gogh d'abord avant les
publications dans la presse il serait
quand même bien qu'on puisse d'abord les
valider je ne sais pas comment cela est
possible parce que je vous dis dit tout
à l'heure où quel mal était fait et puis
je crois qu'il faut vraiment vraiment
parce qu'entre nous mêmes on ne sait pas
trop moi personnellement je suis pas
trois ogm mais a quand même en même
temps je me pose la question c'est la
compétitivité de notre agriculture chez
les autres il utilise les années à venir
en même temps je suis interrogatif parce
que je suis producteur producteurs de
lait pour ce qu'ils ne savent pas notre
métier c'est aussi de nourrir le monde
on sait qui on est 3 milliards de mondes
de personnes à nourrir de plus dans 50
ans alors alors comment on fait est-ce
que les ogm si ces noces il faut surtout
pas les utiliser mais si c'est pas
possible ce serait quand même bête de ne
pas les utiliser donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on aimerait bien voir
beaucoup plus de clarté là dessus
surtout qu'à d'autres le fait c'est pour
ça que je personnellement je pense que
c'est au niveau européen par une chair
par une recherche très indépendante qui
est depuis cette fête donc nous avait
parlé tout à l'heure de moyens moi
personnellement j'y souscris parce que
je crois que c'est vraiment la question
des décennies qui viennent avec madame
nicoué un autre collègue vous savez que
la commission perspective nous a chargés
de faire prospective pardon dans un
chargé de faire un rapport que nous
plierons à quelques mois c'est l'âme ni
coûts qui en est un peu le chef
d'orchestre sur l'avenir des campagnes
bel avenir des campagnes elle va
dépendre aussi de l'agriculture etc l
agriculture c'est difficile de dire en
2040 point 2050 sur l'avenir des
campagnes et je crois que les ogm sont
quand même une des questions dont elle
aimerait savoir alors et puis ma
dernière question aussi c'est avec
l'inra et parce que nous avons quand
même beaucoup confiance atteint cet
institut que nous apporter beaucoup à
l'agriculture quel est votre mode de
fonctionnement
merci merci la dernière demande de
parole dans ce premier nan mais vous
affolez pas on va couper en deux
sinon le directeur se perdent dans la
somme des différentes interrogations
mon âme lienemann s'il vous plaît oui
première question le
indépendance des experts de lens parce
que il me semble quand même qu'il est
important de savoir quels sont les
experts qui sont choisis et comment on a
la certitude qu'ils n'aient aucun
conflit d'intérêts fusse-t-il indirect
avec un certain nombre de des industries
ou des secteurs concernés par et ne
serait-il pas opportun que sur des avis
on puisse avoir la liste annexée des
chercheurs qui ont ou des experts qui
ont été consultés pour pouvoir mesurer
leur réelle indépendance
au regard de ce qu on peut supputer ou
bon même si c'est des fois que des
supputations néanmoins ya un souci de
transparence qui paraît tout à fait
indispensable
la deuxième chose c'est que je pense
qu'en france on a pris beaucoup de
retard dans le développement de la
recherche et de l'enseignement de la
toxicologie nous avions j'avais suivi au
parlement européen à tous qui étaient
autour de reach mais aussi d'autres
secteurs et on voyait qu'on avait des
toxicologues dont l'âge moyen était
supérieur au mien ce qui quand même pose
problème
donc par ailleurs il ya donc un problème
de formation au cid
parce que pour avoir des experts
indépendants faut aussi beaucoup de gens
compétents
troisièmement s'agissant de l' or là
c'est pas directement à lens que s'est
produit c'est quand même que on est en
l'éternel débat que notre collègue
précédent a engagé sur le fait qu'on
voudrait que ce sont européens mais
qu'au niveau européen eba ils veulent
pas il ya des tas de pays projet m très
fortement convaincu que quand on obtient
des décisions comme par exemple celle
qu'on a prise de la non mise en culture
on n'a pas pris de mesure concernant
l'importation de produits que nous
considérons comme ne devons pas être
développé en plein champ chez nous donc
au bout d'un moment effectivement on se
met dans une situation difficile donc
mais ça c'est une question qui n'est pas
celle de lens qui est de savoir jusqu'où
on va quand même arrêter cette
schizophrénie
interdire des choses chez nous et de les
permettre chez les autres pour qu'ils
viennent ventes chez nous quoi bon bout
d'un moment moi je considère que tout ça
ne peut pas tenir alors oui je sais je
connais parfaitement les règlements
européens mais si on fait jamais de bras
de fer avec nos collègues européens
croyez moi les multinationales auront
gagné par rapport aux est assez simple
voilà donc au bout d'un moment il faut
créer des conflits on l'a fait que les
états unis pour les hormones à l'époque
on l'a payé mais on a d'accord mais au
moins n'a pas de vous aux hormones en
europe donc je considère sur un certain
nombre de sujets on peut poser
oui d'accord bien sûr mais c'est tout le
problème de la porte à sion donc
maintenant dire est fondamental que pose
cette question reste que sur la
dépendance de lens je voudrais qu'on
puisse avoir la certitude qu'on puisse
avoir accès aux experts qui ont donné un
avis merci c'était ça la question
ok monsieur le directeur veut vous
répondez à cette première série de deux
questions merci bouge oui je peux
commencer voilà j'ai peut-être commencé
effectivement sur la question de
l'indépendance des experts et de l'
expertise ils ont au niveau de la neisse
emmené c'est de dire on s'est souhaité
mais voilà on a essayé de trouver dit on
un vocable qui se comprenait bien
l'étranger aussi en vidéo voilà on alors
très clairement l'indépendance de
l'expertisé effectivement un élément
mais totalement clé 1 et critique
d'ailleurs qui a fait l'objet de
beaucoup de débats à un moment de la
fusion et on a mis en place
vraiment toute une série de dispositifs
pour
créer les conditions de l'indépendance
de cette expertise le premier élément
c'est au niveau de la sélection des
experts et donc la question de la
prévention des conflits d'intérêt par
rapport à ça on a deux niveaux qui sont
très importants dans le processus le
premier niveau c'est au moment où on
constitue nos colistiers d'experts et on
les renouvelle tous les trois ans je
crois que le renouvellement est un
élément important
d'ailleurs dans le dispositif au moment
dix ans de la sélection des experts pour
nos collectif d'experts on a bien sûr
tout un processus donc à la fois basée
sur la compétence évidemment dont nous
avons besoin est évidemment des
déclarations publiques d'intérêts qui
sont systématiquement demandé et nous
avons tout eu un process internes qui
s'appuie d'ailleurs sur notre conseil
scientifique indépendant par rapport à
la direction de l' agence pour examiner
l'ensemble des candidatures on est
systématiquement dans des logiques
d'appel à candidatures ouvert le plus
ouvert possible parce qu'un des éléments
qu'on cherche c'est d'avoir la plus
grande diversité de chercheurs 1 dans
nos propres collectif d'experts et donc
on sélectionne les experts dans le
collectif d'experts dans la volonté
effectivement de prévenir vision de
d'examiner des liens d'intérêts qui
peuvent exister pour ne pas intégrer
dans nos collectif d'experts des
personnes des chercheurs dont les liens
serait tel qu'il pourrait remettre en
cause leur impartialité dans la
réalisation de leurs travaux
ça c'est une chose mais ce qui ne veut
pas dire un jouet est clair qu' on ne
sélectionne que des experts qui ont des
déclarations publiques d'intérêts vierge
pourquoi parce que enfin vu d'ailleurs
le détail qui est maintenant prévue dans
le cadre de la réglementation je
rappelle quelles nouvelles législations
et réglementations qui a été mis en
place en ce début d'année un chercheur
qui aurait une déclaration publique
d'intérêts vierge
on peut s'interroger un petit peu
honnêtement sur ses activités de
chercheur parce que ça demande à détails
extrêmement précis et une exigence de
transparence très forte
le deuxième niveau qui est extrêmement
important pour nous c'est que au delà
donc la sélection des experts avant
chaque réunion du collectif d'experts
pour
chaque point de l'ordre du jour on fait
ce qu'on appelle une matrice
d'identification des risques de conflit
d'intérêts c'est à dire on va nous en
tant qu'agence et on engage notre
responsabilité là dessus identifier le
fait que tel lien d'intérêt qui n'a pas
été jugé comme rédhibitoire en soi pour
appartenir au collectif d'experts mais
peut se traduire en risque de conflit
d'intérêts sur un dossier particulier et
que dans ce cadre là je dire on laisse
pas l'expert seul la responsabilité de
dire alger peut-être un conflit
d'intérêt nous en tant qu'agence aussi
on le fait et concrètement on est passés
à la pratique aussi de cet aspect là je
vous donne juste un exemple on a eu il
ya quelques mois donc un avis qu'on
devait rendre sur l'est et facteur de
croissance dire dans quelle mesure les
facteurs de croissance il ya dans l'est
sont susceptibles ou pas de favoriser le
développement de cancers bon sujet assez
polémique controversé etc
nous avions donc un collectif d'experts
au niveau nutrition dont il ya eu un
groupe d'experts spécifique qui devait
valider dedans il y avait un certain
nombre d'experts qui appartiennent à
l'institut danone inquiète une fondation
à but non lucratif etc
nous avons néanmoins considéré que sur
un sujet comme ça il n'était pas
possible ça a été mal pris honnêtement
je veux dire parce que tout le travail
qu'on a à faire c'est de veiller à ce
que voilà les chercheurs disent on ne
ressentent pas comme étant une remise en
cause de leur intégrité mais
l'application d'un certain nombre de
règles qui sont essentiels pour la
crédibilité du dispositif
nous avions mis en place ce dispositif
encore une fois à deux niveaux et moi
j'alerte simplement sur le fait que par
rapport au sujet des conflits d'intérêts
qui est majeure et c'est extrêmement
important d'être très rigoureux
mais attention disons à une tendance
quand même qui existent de confondre un
peu liens d'intérêts et conflits
d'intérêts parce qu'on a quand même un
petit risque aujourd'hui honnêtement de
recul un peu de la communauté
scientifique qui voit là s'interroge un
petit peu sur l'intérêt pour eux d'aller
rentrer dans des collectifs d'experts
notamment sur des sujets très
controversée sur lequel ils savent
qu'ils vont être exposés à
éventuellement la moindre 1
communication assez désagréable sur le
fait qu'il suffit qu'ils aient tel ou
tel mot dans leurs déclarations
publiques d'intérêts qui aujourd'hui un
fait une vingtaine de pages un seuil
extrêmement détaillé donc voilà message
c'est qu'on doit être extrêmement
rigoureux ces deux niveaux sont
essentiels mais attention aussi 1,1 des
risques quand même un jour c'est de ne
plus avoir les compétences nécessaires
pour pouvoir faire notre travail est là
le risque
il peut être très important j'ajoute que
derrière un au delà disons de la mise en
place donc de ces collectif d'experts ce
qui est tout aussi fondamental dans
beaucoup de nos sujets ou notamment il
ya des controverses il ya des
incertitudes et otc le caractère
collectif et contradictoire de
l'expertisé fondamentale avec une
méthodologie qu'on a explicité qu'on a
rendu public sur notre site
avec voilà la volonté d'essayer d'avoir
la plus grande pluralité des points de
vue au sein même de nos collectif
d'experts et ça c'est un des aspects qui
est également extrêmement important et
là aussi attention à ce qu'on se
retrouve pas dans une logique où
l'indépendance globale du processus ce
soit jugé à l'aune du maillon le plus
faible
entre guillemets un de tel ou tel expert
parce que encore une fois je crois que
dans beaucoup de cas ce côté collectif
et contradictoire est absolument
fondamentale et puis le troisième
élément pour moi c'est ce que j'ai un
peu évoqué tout à l'heure c'est la
diversité des sources d'information un
sur lequel dix ans on travaille encore
une fois une autre travail où on ne fait
pas nous mêmes la recherche on s'appuie
sur tout ce qui existe et c'est là où
c'est très important je pense que c'est
vraiment un des aspects du débat et puis
le dernier élément un peu cette culture
un d'ouverture aux parties prenantes de
respect et d'écouté des lanceurs
dallaire et la janvier un petit peu à
l'autre
l'autre sujet inquiet est ce que notre
conclusion elle est trop sévère par
rapport à l'étude est haute
moi ce que je voudrais quand même dire
c'est que très clairement en tant
qu'agence on a vous l'avez vu un
souhaitait avoir une attitude
extrêmement respectueuse des uns et des
autres on considère que les lanceurs
d'alert il peut y avoir un côté agaçant
dans la façon de présenter les choses
mais c'est important pour nous d'être à
l'écouté parce que souvent il ya des ya
des messages il ya des signaux 1 qu'il
faut savoir entendre
je crois qu'on a vraiment une attitude
un de ce côté là tout à fait
respectueuse avec la distance nécessaire
nous on veut pas rentrer dans les débats
un dézingue des autres parce que je
crois que c'est pas notre rôle et on
n'aurait pas beaucoup de valeur ajoutée
c'est ce qui nous a permis aussi
d'auditionner gilles eric séralini dans
de bonnes conditions on a eu un bon
dialogue ç'a permis effectivement
d'avoir des éléments d'information
complémentaires
lui même reconnaît d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de limites et souhaite que cette
étude puisse être faite dans un cadre un
différend il reconnaît un certain nombre
de voix la 2de limite 1 par rapport à ça
et je crois que c'était vraiment un
dialogue qui est tout à fait utile mais
une fois donné ça je pense que c'est
aussi notre rôle de dire clairement les
choses sur un plan scientifique
est-ce que je crois que ça fait partie
aussi d'autres éléments de crédibilité
et donc par rapport à l'étude elle-même
oui on dit clairement et je crois que là
on rejoint un peu tout lé collectif
d'experts qui se sont prononcés sur des
limites telles que ça ne permettent
clairement pas sur le plan scientifique
de fonder un lien de cause à effet ça
clairement mais je finirai et je vais
donner la parole à au professeur gérard
lasfargue ventes oem pour apporter un
deux éléments complémentaires c'est que
notre attitude même par rapport aux
plantes génétiquement modifiées
c'est quand même un le fait que notre
rôle c'est en permanence d'anticiper des
des questions complémentaires d'aller
toujours plus loin dans l'état des
connaissances scientifiques parce que
ces technologies
elles sont encore assez récente le nk603
c'est une plante ou via une modification
n'a été apportée pour générer
l'expression d'une protéine qui permet
d'être résistant à l'herbicide roundup
mais on commence à voir des dossiers
dans lequel n'y a pas une protéine y en
a cinq
maintenant de plus en plus d'événements
ça va potentiellement conduire à ce que
la plante génétiquement modifiée soit de
plus en plus éloignés de la plante
d'origine et que le principe qui est le
principe d'équivalence de regarder cette
différence eh bien il ya un jour où
c'est un principe qui risque d'être
dépassé donc notre rôle 1 c'est d'être
en permanence en anticipation d'un
certain nombre d'évolutions et donc pour
nous le débat disons autour de ce cadre
réglementaire bien sûr il faut qu'on
travaille à voir comment la nature des
dossiers peut conduire à des questions
nouvelles et voir comment il faut
documenter scientifiquement les éléments
pour éventuellement est en capacité à
jour de proposer des évolutions dans les
protocoles et c'est ce que nous faisons
donc voilà à peu près disons qu'elle est
notre posture et notre attitude
sur ce dossier comme voilà sur
l'ensemble des dossiers qu'on est amené
à traiter
peut-être jarre lasfargue un mot sur
voilà par rapport disons-le espèces de
rats et voilà un peu des questionnements
sur est ce que voilà on est plus sévère
en étudiant l'étude de serre à nice par
rapport aux études réglementaires ou
autre j'ai déjà dit un mot sur les
espèces de ram est géré à la star gens
dire un mot
oui par rapport à la aux espèces de rats
d'autres été choisi dans l'étude de
gilles-eric séralini c'est pas tant ça
que l'on a critiqué un que les
interprétations qui fait des données de
son étude en termes de résultats sur
l'espèce de rats son choix il nous l'a
motivé quand on l'a auditionné il était
donc de choisir cette espèce de race
prague dollé pourra voir donc
un même protocole avec une même souche
de rats que celles qui sont utiles qui
étaient utilisés dans les études
réglementaires
le seul problème c'est que cette étude
de race prague dole et elle est utile
dans les études de toxicité à plus court
terme a dit reid à 90 jours où les
études de toxicité aiguë dès qu'il
s'agit d'une étude de cancérogènes et
qui doit être mené sur le long terme
cette souche de rats pose des problèmes
parce qu'elle fait un nombre de tumeurs
au spontanée extrêmement important par
exemple pour les tumeurs mammaires qui
ont été étudiés à deux ans vous avez 60
% de tumeurs spontané chez les rats de
façon naturelle sans ans sans traitement
et donc si on veut avoir une puissance
statistique pour se donner les moyens de
conclure s'il ya vraiment un effet la
deûle ogm associé au roundup
il fallait au moins 80 à 100 rappard
groupe
si on voulait avoir une puissance
statistique suffisante ce qui redonnait
un coût de l'étude absolument faramineux
donc si vous voulez il est parti sur une
double hypothèse c'est à dire ben voilà
est-ce que les tests à 90 jours sont
prédictif des faits plus long à plus
long terme sur la cancérogenèse et puis
est-ce qu'il ya effectivement des effets
de cancer attendu et donc il a pris dans
ce cadre là une souche doha que l'on
peut utiliser pour un taux de
cancérogenèse mais qui devrait utiliser
avec un nombre beaucoup plus important
et dans lé protocole habituel quand
série d'études de toxicité aiguë
effectivement on est con et en ondes une
utilisent cette louche de race prague
dole et qu'on saisit d'études de
cancérogenèse c'est d'autres espèces de
rats qui sont en général choisi pour
pouvoir limiter le nombre d'animaux dans
les groupes et et donc les coûts
correspondants d'études puisque c'est
avec l'étude générale est restée rennie
a coûté déjà 3 millions d'euros et si on
veut rajouter de la puissance
statistique avec un nombre beaucoup plus
important d'animaux dans chaque groupe
il faudra monter à 5 10 millions d'euros
voire plus pour une solitude et donc ça
pose la question effectivement derrière
de la problématique des méthodes
alternatives
alors actuellement ce qui est utilisé
donc est-ce qu'on ce qui est exigé dans
le cadre réglementaire notamment pour
les phytosanitaires par rapport à nous
réglementation qui s'est mis en place au
niveau européen on peut avoir un certain
nombre de textes in vitro donc avec des
méthodes alternatives qui sont
extrêmement intéressante pour au départ
identifier des dangers des propriétés de
danger soit de la substance active dans
une préparation phytopharmaceutiques
soit déco formule 1 c'est ce qui est
fait actuellement
donc est ce qu'on demande dans l'est
dans les dossiers qui sont déposés par
exemple d'aider des dangers comme la
génotoxicité d'un produit comme son sont
le risque de voir apparaître des
mutations mutations de gènes ou mutation
de chromosomes où les effets
perturbateurs endocriniens
donc ça avec des tests méthodes
alternatives on peut déjà mettre en
évidence ses propriétés de danger c'est
extrêmement important parce que ça fait
d'emblée écarté un certain nombre de
produits de substances actives au voir
decaux formulant par exemple pour vous
donner une idée sur les herbicides comme
le roundup
il y avait des co formule enquêtait
dérivé du no ni phénol qui sont
maintenant interdits parce qu'on a vu
des propriétaires justement de
perturbation endocrinienne grâce à un
grâce à ces tests
donc il ya un certain nombre de tests
qui ont des capacités prédictives sur
des effets à plus long terme soit de
cancer soit de perturbations
endocriniennes
et ça c'est extrêmement important de les
mettre en oeuvre et vérifier qu'ils sont
bien présents dans les évaluations
réglementaire des des dossiers notamment
pour les produits phytopharmaceutiques
voilà à côté à côté évidemment se repose
la question sur des sp plus spécifiques
voilà de faire des études à plus long
terme comme comme l'a dit notre
directeur général
alors je vous signale que le président
de la commission du développement
durable l'aménagement du territoire à
une réunion à 11 heures aussi je
souhaiterais que vous posiez directement
vos questions
sans faire de déclaration préalable ou
deux pour profiter au maximum de
l'expertisé de notre invité ou de nos
invités est ce qu'une et moi professeurs
et donc j'ai encore six demandes de
prise de parole en sachant qu'il est
moins 16 est donc très succinctement
uniquement les questions monsieur burqa
oui 3 3 questions
ce directeur savait que la question
d'indépendance est une vraie question
plus il ya d'intérêt plus l'indépendance
est difficile et de grandes études
internationales esprit d'épidémiologie
ont été démontrées parfois que des
personnes qui avaient une notoriété
scientifique se se elle a été dilapidé a
ensuite quand on connaît les liens
d'intérêt avec certains groupes
moi je voudrais pas à monsieur le
directeur que la l'étude de monsieur
salini soit soit passé à la trappe
je pense que c'est un coup de tonnerre
qui s'est passé il a ce mérite là et ce
coup de tonnerre était nécessaire parce
que sous des prétextes qu'il faut
nourrir le monde sous des prétextes que
et on était en train de nous proposer
les ogm comme un fait accompli
et si je crois que jamais en relais moi
je pose les questions que je pose la
question mais vous excuser le président
et on doit finir à celle d'une question
importante
je pense qu'elle a elle a eu un rôle et
plus rien ne sera comme avant après la
deuxième chose je vous pose une deuxième
question te plaît le recul des
pesticides
le grenelle avait dit 50% en moins de
pesticides d'ici 2018 qui continue
d'augmenter en ce moment jusqu'où on ira
jusqu où on ira et dernière chose il y
avait une autre étude qui est l
université dalston en angleterre
qui disait que l'effet cocktail ajouter
à l'effet dure et provoquer la maladie
de parkinson et la maladie d'alzheimer
c'est quand même un peu bizarre que ces
études la passe quasiment sous le
boisseau
alors que souvent ce sont des coups de
tonnerre
mais parce que il y a des intérêts
financiers énormes un certain type de
développement de l'agriculture et de
l'agroalimentaire qui fait qu'on passe
ou le sous silence ces études qui sont
pourtant très important voilà les trois
questions merci madame bourget
rapidement rapidement
oui mais il y avait six questions mais
un début en fait après un peu quand même
mais n'entrera sinon au début en son
temps puis après on est pressés nous au
début chacun intervenait qu'on a un
quart d'heure maintenant on intervient
vingt minutes maintenant
bon on va on va en voir je pense que
mais monsieur bourquin je pense que mes
collègues de la commission de l'aude
durable accepteront qui aiment
débordement pour qu'on puisse vider les
questions donc on se donne jusqu'à 11h15
merci monstre mes collègues ils
accepteront merci monsieur le président
et ross je vais éviter de répéter ce qui
a été dit avant moi je parle au nom de
nicole bonnefoy rapporteur de la mission
pesticides et je salue l'analyse qui a
été faite par lens est ce parce qu'elle
a le mérite effectivement de reconnaître
ce qui est dans l'étude séralini
discutable et ce qui est profitable
c'est à dire les lacunes les problèmes
qui se posent à l'avenir et dont on a
bien entendu que vous étiez disposés à
les combler je partage également l'avis
de madame frimas la présidente de la
mission des deux sur les pesticides
parce qu'il faut travailler dans la
sérénité et je voudrais monsieur le
président le directeur pardon vous
indiquer que je ne sais pas ce que ça
veut dire crédibiliser un peu je
préférerais qu'on crédibilise vous avez
à plusieurs reprises un peu moi je crois
que par rapport à l'opinion
voilà par rapport à l'opinion publique
ça ne supporte pas le mi chemin il faut
que ces études soient crédibiliser ce
qui suppose que vous ayez les moyens de
travailler et en particulier par rapport
aux experts vous venez de nous donner
des informations concernant le choix que
vous faites
les mesures de précaution que vous
prenez c'est très bien mais j'ai bien
entendu que healy a besoin de faire
sauter le plafond d'emplois de d'emploi
de l'ansès pour sécuriser
effectivement les études que vous avez
amené dans l'optique de la santé et de
ces mesures
alors je n'ai pas de question mais je
vais conseiller à nos collègues et à
l'opinion publique de lire l'excellent
rapport qui a été fait par madame frimas
et nicole bonnefoy et les
recommandations qui sont faites
concernant notamment l'indépendance des
études concernant les lanceurs d'alert
concernant l'évaluation des
perturbateurs endocriniens et cetera de
façon à ce que à partir de cette étude
là nous puissions travailler avec les
scientifiques et les politiques façon à
faire progresser ce domaine qui est
éminemment délicat merci monsieur dantec
oui je crois qu'on peut considérer si on
est un petit peu provocateur qu'au final
l'étude du professeur séralini a atteint
au moins 90 à 80 pour 15% de ses
objectifs qui étaient de force et la
puissance publique à engager les études
nécessaires
et finalement ce qu'a cherché
séralini ça n'est que ce qu'on retrouve
dans les conclusions d'un certain nombre
d'études précédentes de l'ansès
reprenait sur le site de l'ansès les
avis sur le soja ogm ou autre c'est à
dire ce qui avait amené lens est ce à
dire non à la mise en culture en disant
il n'y avait pas les résultats
donc on pouvait pas le faire et séralini
a cherché finalement ce que lens s avait
pointé comme comme absent c'est le coup
de tonnerre médiatique met donc on voit
bien qu'il ya nécessité de passer par la
case médias fait qu'aujourd'hui enfin la
puissance publique va commander a lancé
au niveau européen
il faut voir comment tout ça va
s'articuler
enfin la recherche de niveau de rigueur
scientifique et financement et de
financement qui va permettre de répondre
à la question
donc moi ma question à partir de l'arbre
c'est de dire comment se fait-il
finalement qu'on ait besoin de passer
par la case séralini c'est à dire on
parle de 2,2 de l'indépendance
aujourd'hui entre guillemets des agences
mais là on voit bien qu'on a une agence
qui médisent avis extrêmement développé
sur les lacunes aujourd'hui des études
existant sur les sur les ogm qui dit bah
on peut pas autoriser vu ce qu'on a
comme comme études donc il nous faudrait
ça ça et ça mais c'est à vide agences de
l'ansès n'ont pas été suivies d'effet
un parle pas un par l'état puisque
l'état n'a pas dit en lisant le rapport
sur le soja par exemple en disant bas
effectivement on vous donne l'argent
bercy des blogs les crédits on lève le
plafond d'emplois non il s'est rien
passé du tout il a fallu que séralini
reviennent pour qu'enfin on essaye de
répondre à la question qui était
parfaitement connu et est cadré dans les
avis précédents relance est donc moi ma
question elle est vraiment là dessus de
dire à votre avis je sais pas quelle
votre capacité
de donner un avis totalement
circonstances il a su comment ça se fait
finalement que la chaîne ne fonctionne
pas c'est à dire que la vie de lagence
dix ans on n'a pas les éléments pour
autoriser ne soit pas suivie de la part
de l'état des puissances publiques voire
des industriels des études nécessaires
et donc qui veut bien dire que le
système tel qu'il est aujourd'hui n'est
pas satisfaisant merci madame me chie
l'ag merci monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur jeu d'abord je
tenais à vous remercier d'avoir changé
le classement du bisphénol a
vous l'avez donc classée en dangerosité
donc je j'apprécie beaucoup puisque
étant donné que j'étais rapporteur
c'était vraiment un plus moi ma question
on va surtout au niveau européen ont
maintenant on a remarqué sur différents
rapport concernant la santé publique la
santé publique c'est vrai que mon
prononcé rarement ces mots comment au
niveau européen vous pouvait faire
pression parce que maintenant il ya
quand même des doutes ya un flou complet
sur tout ce qui est ogm l'importation la
production quand il ya flou on devrait
stopper la production trouver d'autres
moyens puisque c'est vrai qu'on sait
qu'il ya des cancers il ya il ya une
augmentation de parkinson ya plein de
maladies qui sont sûrs qu'ils sont
développés donc moi je en plus au niveau
du citoyen lambda il ya une vraie
cacophonie
on s'en sort plus il n'y a pas un seul
jour ou dans la presse on ne développe
pas des angoisses il y va aussi donc
aussi au niveau de la recherche de nono
les moyens au niveau mondial puisque
c'est vrai aujourd'hui c'est quand même
l'économie on l'économie en imitant les
mises en avant par rapport à la santé
publique
je trouve ça vraiment honteux parce que
c'est vrai que il y va de notre jeunesse
qui suit donc comment pouvons nous deux
ne se donner les moyens pour que aussi
l'europe nous ai quoc nous écouter que
nos députés européens portent ces sujets
en n'ayant pas de lobby merci
merci monsieur vaugrenard où ils ont été
portés au niveau européen mais c'est
très compliqué marie noëlle liennemann
l'évocateur brillement moi j'ai le
sentiment que nous sommes confrontés à
deux éléments qui sont un peu
contradictoire et malheureusement
habituelle d'un côté la crainte et la
peur de plus en plus forte aujourd'hui
peuvent être utilisés pas toujours mais
peuvent être utilisés à des raisons
politiques ou à des fins politiques ça
arrive
d'un autre côté ça arrive également il
peut y avoir le monde de
l'agroalimentaire ou de la grande
industrie qui pour des raisons de profit
à court terme et au mépris de la santé
publique utilise des choses qui ne
devraient pas utiliser et donc moi je
souhaite que pour des raisons de santé
publique n'a encore ce soit la raison
qu'ils l'emportent sur la peur ou sur la
crainte qui trop souvent sont utilisés
pour le très court terme et
éventuellement aussi pour vendre du
papier
donc pour me faire aussi ma propre
opinion même si j'ai bien entendu les
propos tenus par le directeur il me
semble qu'il serait intéressant alors
est ce que c'est possible envisageable
d'auditionner aussi le professeur
séralini et pourquoi ne pas imaginer ce
qui ne se fait rarement au sénat
semble-t-il mais je pense que c'est une
erreur
des auditions contradictoire pour que
nous fassions notre propre opinion et
ensuite pour que nous ayons à intervenir
éventuellement à légiférer
je trouve que nous faisons ou la tête ça
mais moi j'ai encore jamais bénéficié
mais ça fait 15 ans celui-là d'audition
au contradictoire dans quelques
commission d' enquête que ce soit enfin
pour terminer
s'il s'avère aujourd'hui ou s'il
s'avérait demain que le professeur
séralini
utiliser les médias mauvais escient à ce
moment là que commence la spa ce qu'est
ce que il ya des recours juridiques qui
existent parce que la manière d'utiliser
les médias et la communication à des
fins qui n'ont pas forcément grand chose
à voir
éventuellement je suis prudent à la
santé publique sur la santé publique et
des craintes que est d'abord que ça
engendre ensuite c'est condamnable et à
ce moment là quels recours juridique
y at-il dans cette hypothèse bien
entendu sinon c'est toujours des
interrogations un peu partout nous ne
savons pas trop où nous allons donc la
question j'en ai bien conscience
messieurs les présidents de commission
ne s'adresse pas seulement aux
directeurs mais aussi un peu à nous
mêmes
merci monsieur rey wad mois dans un
premier temps je voudrais remercier le
directeur pour la clarté de l'exposé et
la grande expertise l'humilité dans le
propos et la prudence donc l'aspect non
passionnée et c'est important dans ce
domaine et on met tout de suite en
regard l'importance qu'il y a à avoir
les moyens financiers dédiés à cette
recherche et à cette expertise là le le
deuxième le deuxième point c'est le
problème posé par la médiatisation
d'études
je dirais non aboutis ou en tous les cas
insuffisamment expertisé et qui a des
conséquences gérard bailly l'a dit tout
à l'heure dans domaine qui nous concerne
des conséquences en terme économique on
a fragilisé une filière agricole mais
aussi une filière alimentaire et le mal
est fait on ne retrouvera pas la
communication ni l'intérêt des médias
pour
corriger cela le troisième point et
c'est un peu en écho à mon prédécesseur
dans les interventions ou au regard de
la surmédiatisation de de cette étude de
monsieur séralini n'étions pas là dans
le cas de l'article 120 et suivants du
code de la consommation et qui va
jusqu'à manipuler le concept du
dénigrement et je pense que ça pourrait
cela qu'il faudrait mettre en regard on
ne peut pas impunément donner une
médiatisation à des voiles à des
recherches qui ne sont pas abouties qui
ne sont pas qui ne sont pas vérifiées
qui ne sont pas confrontés etc
voilà merci
non mais vous fait sans doute allusion à
le faire du concombre mai
bordeaux qui c'est qui parlait donc je
vous en prie non écoutez mes chers
collègues vous à l'époque rôle entamé le
débat
nous avons la chance d'avoir le
directeur de l'ens cesse avec nous et le
professeur oui donc je souhaiterais
profiter et non pas que vous entamiez un
match entre vous deux noms derrière tout
ça en tous les cas ce que je retiens
c'est qu'ils avaient fait un problème de
recherche indépendante et le problème de
expertise liens d'intérêts et conflits
d'intérêts ces deux choses complètement
différentes et en particulier en
recherche clinique
il y as forcément au moment de la de la
phase clip d'essais cliniques
il ya forcément un lien d'intérêts entre
le fournisseur de la molécule et la
recherche clinique et c'est pas pour ça
qu'il ya conflit d'intérêts et si on
continue à aller trop loin avec le
balancier sur ce genre de liens on
n'aura plus d'experts ça c'est un
véritable problème vous l'avez
d'ailleurs évoqué c'est le problème du
balancier bon je vous laisse la parole à
tous les deux excusez moi
merci monsieur le président je vais
assez rapide merci pour les
contributions des uns dix autres la
première chose madame d'une manne
j'avais oublié de préciser aussi sur le
fait que clairement un la liste des
experts 1 du groupe et bien annexée à la
vie bien et ça c'est systématique soit
cédée collectif d'experts spécialisés
qui sont permanents et de leur
composition est sur le site en
permanence soit c'est des groupes
constituent spécifiquement et à ce
moment là on met systématiquement la
liste d' en annexe à la vie est par
ailleurs toutes les déclarations
publiques d'intérêts sont sur le site 1
c'est c'est un point important
après le côté que l'étude
ainsi rennes ni ne doit pas passer à la
trappe je crois que justement ça a été
soulignée derrière effectivement encore
une fois nous on a une position qui est
clair par rapport à une sur
interprétation des résultats
mais d'un autre côté voilà on a un
certain nombre de propositions alors
clairement on s'interroge effectivement
pourquoi faut avoir ce genre d'étude la
première chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que
objectivement on n'a pas attendu en soit
cette étude pour faire un certain nombre
de choses d'ailleurs vous l'avez vous
l'avez rappelé le cadre européen malgré
tout et je crois qu'on peut dire le plus
exigeant dix ans dans les différentes
régions du monde
aujourd'hui il a progressé au fur et à
mesure mais encore une fois nous
considérons qu'il y a effectivement des
choses à faire et donc nous
effectivement sur plusieurs dossiers on
a une idée affidés favorable dans la
mesure où n'étaient pas intégrés dans
les dossiers pour l'évaluation un
certain nombre d'exigences que nous nous
considérons comme nécessaires et en
particulier autour un de ces essais 10 à
90 jours et avec des éléments en termes
de puissance statistique suffisante pour
réduire très fortement le risque de
passer à côté
disons d'un événement un qui mériterait
d'être regardée plus près alors
typiquement nous ce qui nous a un peu
marqué c'est qu'on voit bien qu'à partir
du moment où il ya de bonnes raisons je
crois vraiment pour ça la réglementation
n'impose pas de façon systématique des
essais à deux ans il ya vraiment de
bonnes raisons pour ça et la
problématique aussi de veiller à
n'imposer des expérimentations animales
que quand c'est nécessaire est un
élément très important à prendre en
compte mais le fait que ça ne soit pas
obligatoire fait que on constate qu'il
ya très très peu d'études disponibles et
c'est là où on considère que ça vaut la
peine
et notamment ce qui nous intéresserait
c'est d'essayer de mieux travailler 1
pour voir si ces essais donc nous qu'on
préconise de façon systématique à 90
jours donc c'est du sub chronique
1 c'est un peu un équivalent d'une
dizaine d'années un de consommation côté
côté humain si on veut avec toutes les
précautions à prendre sur les
transpositions dans quelle mesure ces
études peuvent être de bons sentinelles
a éventuellement détecter des signaux
par rapport à voilà à des effets à plus
long terme et que dans ce cadre là ce
qui manque un typiquement par exemple
dans l'étude séralini c'est que nous
n'avons pas voilà toute l'analyse de
toute une série de paramètres à cette
étape de 90 jours 1 permettant un
d'analyser un peu
dans quelle mesure il ya des signaux
qu'on peut détecter à 90 jours et qui
pourrait conduire au cas par cas on
parle de décider qu'il serait nécessaire
de faire des études complémentaires
c'est énorme en termes de raisonnement 1
c'est d'essayer de voir voilà quelles
sont les méthodes alternatives à des
essais systématique de très long terme
sur toute la durée de la vie qui
permettent de réduire très fortement le
risque de passer à côté d'un signal qui
pourrait se manifester dans le dans le
temps donc ça fait typiquement partie
des questionnements sur lequel je vois
là on souhaiterait travailler avec
d'autres à la mise en place de
protocoles très élaborés bien définir
les objectifs qu'on poursuit et d'avoir
vraiment une méthodologie qui correspond
bien à la réalisation de ces objectifs
donc c'est effectivement dans ce cadre
là un que la capacité à pouvoir
mobiliser effectivement des fonds sur sa
tempe d'études d'envergure parce que
c'est nous paraît un complément utile
pour crédibiliser et vous avez tout à
fait raison pas un peu un site tout à
fait d'accord on doit être extrêmement
disons stricte et ferme sur voilà tout
ce qui peut conduire à créer ou à
recréer la confiance puisque c'est
l'objet un rossi du travail qu'on essaye
de mener
alors après les questions sur la
consommation de produits phytosanitaires
donc ça c'est des sujets qu'on était
beaucoup évoquaient effectivement dans
la mission dont il ne relève pas très
directement disons de du rôle de la nes
la seule chose que je peux dire c'est
qu'on voit aujourd'hui monter le nombre
de dossiers que l'on reçoit sur des
produits alternatifs 1 d'autres types
disons de deux substances que des
substances chimiques qui concrètement ne
vont pas nécessairement complètement
remplacé mais qui au moins peuvent
permettre en combinaison à réduire 1
le recours à des substances chimiques
mais ça voilà c'est tout le plan
ecophyto 2018
effectivement avec un certain nombre de
questionnements la nécessité aussi voir
dans la durée comment effectivement les
choses vont pouvoir évoluer
je laisse par guess cadets
être parce que je suis pas tout à fait
satisfait de la réponse
la question qui était qui était posée
c'était plus de dire sans revenir sur
l'aspect scientifique
séralini haute de dire voilà lancés çà a
émis un avis en un monde séralini
utilisé on n'a pas les études donc on
peut on ne peut pas autoriser et
derrière l'état n'a rien fait c'est dire
et puisque la question une partie des
questions du débat portait sur
l'indépendance aujourd'hui des agences
est ce que ça ne veut pas dire et ça
avait été mis assez clairement je les
cités dans ma déclaration j'ai sur le
débat sur l' expertise
un rapport qui étaient là semblent
assurés qui dira une des questions
posées n'est-elle pas du coup de se dire
lagence doit avoir la mainmise sur son
budget et sur ces emplois et ne doit pas
être dans une négociation au cas par cas
avec les différents ministères de
tutelle pour aller chercher ces
financements pour elle-même être en
capacité de hiérarchiser les questions
principales qui se posent et dans ce cas
là vous auriez été vous même en
situation de dire là il ya un enjeu
majeur on a pas dans ce qui est
aujourd'hui dans les publications de la
capacité
donc nous on va les chercher où le
financer avec d'autres agences à
l'échelle européenne
mais est-ce que c'est sur cette question
là que je vous ai interrogé
moi par rapport à ça le débat me dépasse
un peu aussi bien pour partie clairement
déjà sur disons les propositions qu'on a
fait en fait début 2011 c'est vrai que
non pas que rien n'a été fait mais ça
prend beaucoup de temps
1 c'est à dire vont probablement être
maintenant prochainement intégrer les
propositions qu'on a fait il a fallu se
battre mais les ministères nous ont
aidés à 1 malgré tout dans ce cadre là
mais c'est vrai que ça prend du temps et
que on est à peu près deux ans plus tard
et que l'intégration dans le cadre
réglementaire n'a pas encore été
complètement complètement réalisées
après bas pour ce qui est des
financements bas enfin moi je peux
difficilement disons répondre 1 par
rapport à ça ce que je peux honnêtement
dire aujourd'hui c'est effectivement le
contexte budgétaire est complexe et ce
qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure sur
l'épreuve de plafond d'un poil là c'est
juste un aspect très spécifique c'est
qui ce trouve que sur l'évaluation des
produits phytosanitaires
en fait on est maintenant dans une
réglementation ou les industriels décide
de déposer leurs dossiers dans un des
pays de la région il ya trois grandes
régions on est dans la zone sud donc
avec l'espagne le portugal l'italie la
grèce compte tenu de la situation
économique dans ces pays tous les
dossiers arrivent chez nous donc on a
les dossiers on a l'argent pour évaluer
les dossiers puisque ce sont des taxes
effectivement on a cette difficulté que
de ne pas pouvoir recruter les personnes
dont nous avons besoin temporairement
éventuellement en tout cas en adaptation
ce qui est clair au niveau de l'agencé
que non on ne bradera pas le travail
d'évaluation des dossiers donc en tout
état de cause
ça se traduit concrètement aujourd'hui
par la constitution d'un certain nombre
de stocks et de délais qui ne s'est pas
souhaitable mais voilà c'est la
situation c'était pour éclairer un peu
plus spécifiquement les choses
oui je voulais simplement rajouter un
petit quelque chose par rapport à la
question qui a été posée sur le problème
des maladies neurodégénératives
parkinson alzheimer et c'est peu dire
qu'effectivement il ya un certain nombre
d'études expérimentales qui pointe et
surtout la problématique des pesticides
et du lien que manny parkinson qui est
assez renom d'études épidémiologiques
chez l'homme qui également ont mis en
avance donc en mis en avant cela cette
suspicion dont donc des effets
sanitaires des pesticides dans ce cadre
là il ya une commission des maladies
professionnelles dont qui existe dans le
cadre du régime agricole pour qui dans
lequel on a rapporté je demande un
certain nombre de ces études et qui a
permis donc de reconnaître dans un
tableau des maladies professionnelles la
manip et neeson comme une conséquence de
l'exposition aux pesticides d'une façon
générale ce qui permettra probablement
de pouvoir derrière avancé non seulement
en terme de réparation de maladie
professionnelle si un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs mais aussi en termes de
prévention évidemment d'ailleurs chez
scea great
donc juste parce qu'on me rappelle sur
deux points 10 ans sur lequel je n'ai
pas répondu assez clairement d'une part
par rapport à la question de faire des
auditions contradictoires simplement
d'informer que pardon oui mais c'est
vous même qui le ferait l'office
parlementaire donc lopes qu après vu
effectivement l'organisation d'auditions
en présence de l'auteur gilles eric
séralini 1 le 20 novembre prochain
donc nous y participerons bien sûr en
tant qu'agence et puis d'autre part il y
avait des questions par rapport à la
collaboration avec l'inra 1 qui sont des
collaborations extrêmement fructueuse et
lille / ou un peu tous nos sujets bien
entendu et d'ailleurs on s'appuie vous
l'avez d'ailleurs vue sur la composition
du groupe d'experts il ya un certain
nombre de chercheurs qui viennent de
l'inra dans ce dans ce groupe d'experts
après voilà nous en tant qu'agence on
n'est pas donneur d'ordres vis-à-vis de
l'inra à leur dire faut que vous fassiez
sur vos propres budgets telle étude 1 on
peut bien sûr discuté on peut échanger
mais c'est vrai que il ya une interview
d'ailleurs du président de l'inra qui
disait que c'était pas forcément disons
de leur ressort et c'est là où justement
le débat est intéressant pour voir
comment clarifier le rôle des uns et des
autres sur la réalisation de ce type
d'étude d'envergure qui encore une fois
sur un plan strictement scientifique
n'est pas forcément spontanément les
types disons de travaux de recherches
que mène en priorité les équipes de
recherche d'un organisme comme l'inra ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il ne travaille pas
sur des enjeux sanitaires
mais c'est vrai que là on est sur des
grosses études qui sont cadrés par des
protocoles extrêmement précis et donc
voilà on a un peu ce questionnement sur
lequel effectivement faut éviter de
donner le sentiment que chacun se
renvoie la balle que voilà on va nous
dire l'organisme de recherche c'est pas
eux mais c'est l'agent cela gens ce
qu'ils disent on n'a pas les moyens
disons de commanditer ce genre de choses
et c'est dans ce cadre là que
l'expérience qui existent effectivement
aux états unis avec ce programme est
encore une fois c'est sans revendiquer
que ce soit nécessairement au niveau de
la neisse en tant que tel ça peut être
effectivement au niveau européen c'est à
dire le questionnement une plusieurs
questionnements sur l'europe c'est clair
quand même que nous on essaye un de
veiller à éviter
disons déduplication un aussi
d'expertisé de travaux parce qu'on est
dans un cadre réglementaire qui est
européen donc on contribue à essayer de
pousser un aussi haut niveau européen ce
qu'un certain nombre de choses évoluent
mais c'est clair que au regard de
l'ampleur de ce genre de travaux il
serait intrinsèquement plus satisfaisant
que ça puisse se faire à l'échelle
européenne
ceci dit il faut que les mécanismes
puisse être trouvée et aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que l'expérience monde ce n'est pas
toujours événement très simple le
président vous n'avez pas répondu à la
question sur les chercheurs de
l'université d'aston en angleterre qui
demande à l'europe d'arrêter d'analysé
séparément les phytosanitaires et qui
met en cause l'effet cocktail et l'effet
duré aussi alors dans les relations des
phytosanitaires aujourd'hui on a
commencé au niveau de l' agence donc
dans les relations des préparations que
que l'on a en charge d'évaluer donc à
évaluer justement les poly exposition
alors particulier quand il ya deux
substances actives par exemple dans une
même préparation donc évaluer séparément
chaque substance épi donc l'effet
conjoint éventuellement des deux
substances pour voir si un effet daddy
tivité d'aidé et des effets toxiques ou
au contraire en effet synergique
interactif tni lucas techno nous on a
commencé à le faire voilà et et en
videmment on milite au niveau européen
pour que c'est pour l'exposition
commence à être prise en compte dans
l'évaluation bien entendu ce qui n'est
pas encore le cas actuellement de façon
officielle
merci monsieur le président simplement
la question qui a été posée tout à
l'heure à la fois par un certain nombre
d'entre vous sur un problème
mettons que vous alliez détectée vous ne
pouvez pas l'imposer à l'inserm vous
pouvez pas l'imposer à l'inra vous
pouvez pas l'imposer aux autres
le pst alors comment on peut s'en sortir
si vous aviez détectés par une
méta-analyse un problème sérieux ou un
risque sérieux je vois pas quel est le
système le parcours de décision alors
d'une part donc nous on a dans les avis
qu'on aimait on aimait éventuellement un
certain nombre de recommandations de
recherche par exemple donc ses
recommandations bon elles sont rendues
publiques éventuellement donc on les
porte ensuite par exemple dans le
système des alliances on a des liens
avec avis ann ée à l'envi en particulier
donc c'est des lieux où effectivement on
peut simplement on voit bien les chaînes
de temps n'est évidemment pas la même
1 et c'est une des raisons pour lequel
on considère qu'il serait encore une
fois pertinent de pouvoir dans des cas
particuliers avoir un mécanisme qui voit
là nous permet nous même de mobiliser
mais d'une façon générale dans le cas
habituel et bien voilà on va exprimer un
certain nombre de besoins ça va
s'inscrire effectivement dans le cadre
des discussions on a des relations et
évidemment avec la nr 1 agence nationale
de la recherche également
mais voilà on a un peu une question
d'échelle de temps je rajoute aussi
qu'on a au sein de l' agence un peu de
crédit pour faire réaliser un certain
nombre d'études et de recherches mais
pas du tout pour des études de cette
ampleur c'est à dire vont soutient un
certain nombre de projets de recherche à
200000 euros 300000 euros et c'est utile
1 sur les effets cocktails par exemple
on soutient un certain nombre de projets
dans le cadre d'appels d'offres ouvert
et ça c'est une bonne chose et c'est
vraiment des bons stimulant vraiment
très ciblée sur des travaux 1 qui vise à
mieux documenter des impacts sanitaires
de tel ou tel type 1 de dossier mais là
on est dans une configuration on est
plus sur une crosse étude 1 qui va
nécessiter effectivement des moyens que
nous n'avons pas hélas
sue bat voilà notre notre capacité c'est
d'alerter les ministères c'est de
pouvoir disent on discutait encore une
fois au niveau national ou au niveau
européen le modèle entre guillemets
auquel je fais référence c'est aux états
unis un modèle qui est au niveau fédéral
inquiets interagences simplement une
petite piste vous pourriez avoir un
droit de tirage sur les programmes
blancs de la nr éventuellement mais
monsieur le président je vous laisse
il faut malheureusement clore ce débat
moi ce que je retiens c'est que on a eu
dans le passé des expériences qui ont
montré que toute façon le ministère où
le gouvernement n'avait pas échappé à
des responsabilités dont il ya deux
niveaux qui me paraissent essentiels
c'est de trouver donc la possibilité
d'aller à l'échelon européen parce que
c'est un petit peu ridicule de voir
plusieurs pays se se lancer dans des
dépenses qui sont sur le même sujet et
deuxièmement je pense que ces agences
vos agences je crois qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que d'alerter le
ministère concerné du ministère de la
santé et celui ci doit prendre ses
responsabilités quant à premièrement
débloquer des crédits nécessaires
spécifiques s'il estime que notre pays a
une spécificité face au danger et
deuxièmement trouvé la solution pour
coordonner l'action européenne
on tourne autour du pot mais on a eu
dans le passé des ministres condamnés
non je pense pas qu'on puisse échapper à
la responsabilité politique aux trois
niveaux au niveau de prendre en
considération le rapport de l' agence
sert du lanceur d'alert de le prendre en
compte pour la possibilité de débloquer
des finances et troisièmement de faire
son affaire de créer le réseau européen
est nécessaire qu'au qu'on puisse
travailler ensemble et répartir ensemble
et nous aurons à revoir ces trois
problèmes dans le cadre de du projet qui
a été proposé la commission sur lequel
aujourd'hui on a trouvé une véritable
dimension qu'on n'avait pas toujours
évoqué lorsqu'on a discuté de ce projet
voilà ce l'ouvrir
surtout les cales à vous deux d'être
venu ce matin nous éclairer merci marc
mortureux directeur général de l'ansés
agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
était donc auditionné hier par la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat
une audition qui portait sur l'avis émis
par son agence concernant l'étude du
professeur séralini sur les effets à
long terme des ogm
la très bonne journée à tous sur public
sénat